so Disney's new Snow White Star her name
is Rachel zler here she is criticizing
the original Disney movie as predatory
the original cartoon came out in 1937
and very evidently so um there is a big
focus on her love story um with a guy
who literally stalks her yeah weird
weird Weir so we didn't do that this
time the cartoon's so beloved it's like
a Monumental moment in film history it
was like the first feature length
cartoon movie I love uh the everything
that the Disney company has put out in
the past million years 100 years this
year instead of trying to destroy Snow
White a story that everyone uh remembers
that everyone watched when they were a
kid and nobody thought it was about
predatory behavior or or anything evil
how about you guys create new things but
Disney can't create new things because
wokeness is the end of creativity